I'm gay I'm gay I'm gay I'm gay I'm gay
I'm gay
when did everyone realize they were gay
um
probably like end of high school after
my first relationship it was a girl and
it was just not for me um I think for me
it was in Middle School it was like
before puree so I was just kind of
figuring things out for myself and also
other kids were understanding too so
that really helped me to find myself and
I would talk about it
team oh so I know exactly what it was I
grew up in a very religious home and I
too was in relationships with with girls
so what I did was I I hid I hid myself
for a long time so it's I'm trying not
to tear up
um it wasn't until the pandemic when I
came out to my little brother I actually
knew when I was eight
um my grandma took him to see Mamma Mia
and if you have seen the movie you know
the beach scene you know exactly what
I'm talking about and I knew something
was just a little bit off about me when
I realized that I was more attracted to
Skye than I was Sophie I'm like
something about him you know mine
honestly is right after Twilight came
out look at Robert Pattinson I don't
know whose team whose team okay of
course of course um Pattinson for sure
um Edward I knew in Middle School like
there was something up with me I was
like I like men that's 100 but I called
myself bisexual and then freshman year
in high school I was just like I'm gay
like the way I feel about women is not
nothing like the way I feel about men
okay I already revealed mine but what is
everyone's favorite celebrity cross mine
is also a vampire it's Paul Wesley from
Vampire Diaries
yeah really yeah okay well mine was
Robert Pattinson yeah
Ross Lynch something about that man it's
just oh just ah I just love Ross Lynch
yeah Prince and Idris Elba
mine was mine right now I think is Pedro
Pascal you're on the Pedro Pasco yeah
yeah I am I'm your daddy my bomber uh
from White Collar I love like the Snake
Eyes is so sexy that's it what do you
guys hate about straight men
their inability to like take criticism
or take no as an answer like what is up
with that like I understand patriarch
and all that but still I know like
consent literally
um their inability to have any sort of
fashion it's just t-shirts
t-shirts jeans or like just basketball
shorts you know you see those men who
clearly use like the three in one
shampoos and I'm just like oh my God
they brush their teeth with it yeah oh
my God there's one guy had a 10 in one I
did not even want to ask what it meant
Lucifer I just wanted to ask you um so
you said at 15 is when you knew right
that you were gay yes that's when I came
to terms with it for myself and then you
said like during covid it was when you
told your brother yes so that whole time
he didn't know no really how did that
feel for you
because were you guys close or we were
but I moved from Memphis when I was 18.
okay we've been long distance for all
that time he really didn't make a big
deal out of it just told me that he
loved me no matter what I see well I can
can I ask why did you not come out to
him earlier if you guys felt so
comfortable together with that were you
supportive yes so for me when I was
growing up the thing that mattered most
was getting married and having a family
I had to keep that facade a long time I
was actually practicing to be a minister
in 2012. right when uh President Obama
uh declared gay marriage uh legalized
Nationwide and when I was in
I want to hear more hey have you spotted
the mole yet well hang tight because
we're gonna get there until then
subscribe to our Channel and now let's
get back to the video
[Music]
that that tank top that he's wearing is
is really tacky
sorry just the jeans and a shirt
good luck guys
it kind of hurted a little bit kind of
hurted why do you think they were
suspicious of you
um mainly because I'm wearing just jeans
and a t-shirt but I look stylish and I
look amazing so
I'm Lucifer I remember you were
mentioning that like gay marriage was
being legalized in 2012 but it was 2015
right 2013. that's 2013. yeah okay yeah
so like yeah because it was I remember
it precisely I was I was on the phone
with my pastor actually when that
announcement was made he was running in
2012 so yeah he would have right so 15.
16. I'm bad at math I'm terrible well it
took it took a while for it to actually
go into legislation so you can say 2012
but if you're technically yes it did
take a look okay a few years into that
second term before it was actually
registered what are some things you look
for in a guy oh creativity
um style and confidence number one will
be hygiene yeah I bathe at least twice a
day if you know not more in a drought so
baby please look you know I gotta
freshen up so I expect that from someone
else yeah yeah no I get that I get that
yeah yeah my boyfriend every time I
order my ex-boyfriend yeah every time
I'd come in like the room is just super
messy and like I'm really big on
bathroom cleanliness yes it's the last
place you are at night in the first
place you're on exact and most
traditional men are just um dirty in the
bathrooms right
um for me definitely funny and I mean
obviously you have to look good
that's yeah that's not started though
mine is basically somebody that could
just hang and buy everything I'm a very
active person whether that be like I'm
going out hiking I go out working out
hype doesn't really matter I mean
haven't found anybody as tall as me yet
um how are you six six okay how about
you uh six two but I have these on right
now so a little bit taller I love those
by the way okay they're brand new me too
me too look at I love dogs these are the
brand new model they have yeah I know I
saw those I saw those did you miss the
memo that we were supposed to wear boots
there yes yeah I did you know I do
prefer men that are shorter than me
um a little more on the submissive side
um I hate the bottom oh
um
all right I'm just being I'm just being
honest I guess because I was in such a
controlled environment for so many years
I just have a way of controlling that
space can we run down and say what we
are like you already answered yes we'll
say bottom top
or verse I say I'm a first top yeah
first bottom he's definitely a bottom
Ricky is a bottom for shirt did you see
what this man is wearing had the mid
drift and all yeah it just takes the
right person for me yeah I agree I think
it's very dependent but honestly like
the verse comes in more so when it's
with like hookups and stuff like that
well baby I'm a Scorpio so like me too
oh thanks
so nice
[Music]
when my doctor Lucifer that that was I
was like okay that was a little that was
a little straight that felt very hetero
to me ew oh and my other thing if
they're open to threesomes because I
want to do that they say it to the
camera
he's looking if you were out there and
you're open to threesomes this number is
available here I think it's better on
paper I'm not gonna I just want to break
the truth to you really because it's
just like it's just another person it
just gets a lot I don't know I just feel
like I completely agree it's more of a
novelty for sure
sitting around one person when does my
turn
no it's like two at a time I mean it's
like great
let's do a round of smash or pass
Dominic Fike smash smash Michael B
Jordan
Creed Three oh my three three The Rock
IES
oh my God wait that's that's so
surprising to me because you said that
you were a top like you like being in
control dude the rock yeah
shorter than you wait yeah I am but I
mean it's huge I haven't watched
wrestling for a long time too
[Music]
ain't nobody talking topping The Rock
come on
sus Rock's ugly
good luck gentlemen thank you
oh they [__] they jealous
they see they see they see um totally
star power they just didn't want to
share the money with me I'm not someone
that gets offended easily
but [__] that offended me
I am offended this is this this I'm
talking about this makes no damn sense
look at me
what
do I look straight to you
come on if you want to continue playing
because you think that there's
potentially still alive among the four
of you in the Box raise your hand on
three all right one two three point
raise your hands continue playing yes
I'm not sure so you more confident that
the mole is out is that correct
I think so I can unconfidently say yeah
there's like my besties right here
so that means the game has ended
the Box turns green you have correctly
voted the mole out and you four will
share a cash prize
and the Box turns red that means the
mole is still among you for it and they
win the cash prize themselves
are you guys ready
[Music]
God I I knew I was uncomfortable
this is
one of you aren't my besties
all right
so the mole has won
and on the count of three
I got the mole step forward
one
two three
guys look at us we are besties after all
I was very confused
you have me with the fit Ricky yes did
my girlfriend's tea
yeah I thought everybody misheard the
question dude I I took a step and I was
like are these people stupid like why is
everyone else stepping out like I'm only
straight do you all are gay I thought
that everyone was was gay and either of
you ever been mistaken as gay or more
feminine yeah
for a long time I know every night I
feel like when I go out with my friends
or whatever if I get hit on by more guys
than girls sometimes and yeah it's a
it's very common yeah I got a mistaken
for being gay a lot of the time I even
I'll be honest I went on dates with guys
because so many people were suspecting
me of it but I was just like that's not
me after being on those dates I was like
I like women that's a that's a fact my
story that I was telling was very
genuine I'd suppressed my I guess my
alternative to being Macho straight for
a long time because I just don't fit the
mold for the typical straight guy
there's always questions of is he or
isn't he [__] hell dude
foreign
I've been training for this for a week
how did you train for it bro I faced on
all my gay homies they were saying like
I'm gonna be a verse top because that's
like the least sucks but it's also gay
do I practice walking I practice my fits
I was doing like 360 Snapchat videos
like damn do I look gay or not like does
my ass Pop I work at Urban Outfitters
there's a lot of gay men he helped me
picked up this nail polish I called all
my gay friends and I watched like a
whole bunch of drag I watched so much
drag bro like and it's actually really
good so I would probably keep watching
like after this I think my game plan was
to just uh not offend anybody I hope I
hope I stuck to that I was because I'm
very inclusive I applied for this
episode because especially right now
with the whole red pill movement Aiden
Ross Andrew Tate the toxic male um
influences out there that it's very
important to show like other men and
especially younger men that are coming
up into this world that it is okay to be
feminine is it is it okay to express
your emotions is it okay to be
vulnerable except everyone it doesn't
matter what your looks sexuality gender
are just accept everyone everyone's a
little bit different and don't be mad if
you're not as confident as the people
who are like not jump into conclusions
and not like stereotyping anyone uh
letting them speak for themselves
yeah I changed my lock screen to a dude
as well bro this is my homie Nick bruh
he's in the bed I said yo send me a
selfie with you with your nipple you
send it yeah but I put a picture of mine
because I was like if I turn my phone on
they see my photos